Okay, so now that we've been able to play sound at a really slow rate,
here is your next challenge.
You should add a new button to the scene and
change its image to look like that of a rabbit.
By the way, this image is available for you to use in the instructor notes.
You should also add constraints to this button so
it shows up in the top right hand corner of your phone.
Once you're done with this, you can create an action for
this button and play the movie quote at a really fast speed.
To complete this user interface,
you can add a stop button at the bottom of the screen.
This button should stop any audio from playing.
All of this should take you a while to do.
But by now you have the necessary skills to accomplish all of this.
Here are all the challenges one more time.
Check this box when you are done.